heads up guys my name is Asher no and
today we are going to be talking about
Sparky and what's going on with that and
what's going on with pretty much every
project I have here on my youtube
channel but particularly we're going to
be focusing on Sparky so the biggest
question I've been getting lately is
what is going on with Sparky why have I
stopped these Sparky videos why am I not
live streaming what's going on with
everything really is the is the big
question so this video is going to
outline more or less the details of what
I'm actually working on right now with
Sparky and hopefully it will open up
some opportunities for me to actually
create some videos for you guys so you
can see what I'm working on rather than
keeping you warm in the dark which is
kind of what's going on right and I
might also touch on game programming and
the future kind of that I know I made a
video recently about that but things
have somewhat changed and going to
perhaps touch on that a little bit but
basically this video is going to be
about what on earth is going on so first
of all one of the best ways for you to
actually keep in touch with Sparky and
all of that stuff is to actually follow
me on github because the reason you
should do that and the reason you should
follow this Sparky repository over here
but you can see on the screen is because
this is really the place where you'll
see the change is happening so if you
look at the commits for example I
haven't actually been committing lately
because I'm working on some very very
very very large features that will take
a long time to to to actually complete
but you can kind of see what I've done
okay and you can actually browse the
repository and see what's going on with
that and that's something that you can
kind of keep track off if you if you
just want to know what's happening with
the project but aside from that let's
talk a bit about what what specifically
sparky is going to turn into and what
i'm actually working on so here's the
deal i'm actually working on two major
features right now which are taking a
lot of time okay the first of which is
actually a tool rather than a future so
what I'm working on right now tool wise
is actually basically a clr generator so
Sparky CLI as you may know
real life setting for common language
infrastructure not command line
interface in this case essentially what
what CLI is and what that means is
essentially it's a c++ CLI project which
enables me to essentially wrap all of
the C++ engine code so that I can
actually use it in c-sharp okay because
the idea is we want to be able to use
the for example if we just go to like ah
let's just go to something like the
window you can see this is literally
just a wrapper that wraps around all the
actual C++ code in a way and basically
it is kind of in like a managed class
that can actually be used in C++ land so
that's kind of the idea or rather in
c-sharp land so the reason this is
happening and the reason this is
important to the project is because it
essentially enables you to actually
develop applications for Sparky in
c-sharp now you might be asking me why
is that important the reason that's
important like the major reason that's
important is for tools okay so such as
like a level editor for example or a
like a model viewer or anything anything
like that right any kind of tools that
actually require the engine particularly
the graphical kind of rendering side of
the engine you would want to make them
in c-sharp ideally you would make them
in c-sharp and something like WPF you
can use windows forms winforms if you
like but WPF is kind of a model when you
do that and of course you do need to be
using the engine to render everything
and then you can kind of build your
interface and whatnot on top of that and
it's much much it's much better to do
that than to actually use C++ and like
some kind of GUI tool kit or something
that's pretty much it that's just pretty
much a terrible way to do things I want
you go to there like a very large team
or a lot of time on your hands that does
limit cross-platform support the pretty
much means that only windows users will
be able to use it but you know when you
think about it or at least in my opinion
windows is pretty much all you need for
actual game development for Sparky so
I'm you know if you want to use mac or
linux to develop games
poor Sparky then you can certainly do
that but you'll actually have to write
the code yourself and compiling all the
scenes together might have to be done
magnoli rather than actually using a
tool like an editor windows is what you
should use is kind of what everyone uses
in the industry and I think that it's
pretty much the smart choice especially
because I don't have a full development
team to work on cross-platform support
for the tool thing as well as the engine
engine will still be cross-platform the
runtime will still be cross-platform but
anyway the point is that's why there
needs to be some kind of CLA wrap up
okay now the problem with the way that
I've set this up right now is first of
all you can see it's not complete the
only thing we've got in graphics
religious shaders and window basically
the minimum the minimal amount of
classes to get something to show up on
the screen this is all done manually by
me and that's usually how you would do
it right you just type out the code and
you'd wrap everything the problem is
with a project such as Sparky where the
API frequently changes and I mean really
frequently like the actual the full
complete API changes with every commit
right because I'm it's very young it's
very much in development on constantly
adding features and I'm constantly
breaking the API which would mean that I
would have to manage I'd have to
maintain this CLI manual it which would
be absolutely awful it would take me
basically as much time as it would to
actually make the engine which is just
terrible not to mention it's quite
boring so what I'm making right now is a
tool which will automatically generate
this C sharp code or rather this c++ CLI
code for me autumn automagically I
should say okay so it's going to
basically read all of the all the source
files from the actual engine from Sparky
core and it's going to output Sparky CLI
versions of that okay it's pretty cool
i'm using clang as the passer
essentially for all that code and it's
pretty much eighty percent complete I've
called right now so it's almost done and
I'm going to probably commit that into a
separate repository it'll probably be an
external link here called Sparky tools
or something like that but um that's the
basic idea so that's actually almost
done which is awesome the other reason
that that's that's really important
apart from just being able to use it for
tools
wat is is because of basically just like
a sandbox having a seizure up sandbox
and you can see I've already got one
actually this kind of demonstrates a bit
of the so this is just like mouse
position literally and just printing out
to the console right now but basically
the cool thing with this is that if I
want to teach you guys for example a new
feature like let's learn about how to
implement blue today right or something
like that I can actually use the setup
sandbox and make a video on how to
implement bloom for example and the cool
thing with that is again it's going to
be really simple to do because it's in
c-sharp and there's not fold it c plus
plus up in the way but you still get all
the performance benefits from having C++
as the engine and and whatnot so it's
it's quite it's really really good for
just playing around with and
experimenting with certain things
without having to actually go into C++
land although if I was writing an actual
game like probably not like a love and
air game potentially but like an actual
commercial gamer would obviously do that
and C++ but that's just something to
think about so anyway that's the CLI
side of it the other side of it is
actually more or less engine code
neither is committed yet it's also in
progress but basically another big thing
that I'm doing is I'm actually changing
the entire rendering API what I mean by
that is right now we're using OpenGL of
course so if we go into something like
batch renderer which is our main render
right now 2d renderer you can see that
it's filled with GL calls ok so it's
filled with essentially a bunch of calls
to all this OpenGL stuff that's a
problem the reason that's a problem is
because I eventually want to integrate
direct3d into this as well so that we
can use both the directx and opengl as
our rendering platforms essentially as I
rendering api's so because i won't
direct3d support it's going to be
obviously very very difficult to have
that by just hard coding opengl
everywhere so what I'm doing is I'm
actually extracting that into into a
like a platform type deal into an
abstraction layer so that um we can
essentially just have a generic kind of
you know API draw elements or something
function and then based on which
implementation you decide to use it will
either use open shell or direct ready to
actually perform that GPU operation okay
so that's the idea that's that's one of
the things I'm doing in that of course
is taking a lot of time it's not really
it's not essentially it's not difficult
or anything like that but it's just very
time consuming okay and that's also
going to work with all this stuff for
example so like the current way to
specify the text layouts as you can see
is um is pretty messy it's just the
opengl raw kind of way and that's not
very nice I've actually written a much
better system for how you can just push
a bunch of types essentially and it will
calculate most of this stuff for you
automatically and you can just basically
push a bunch of types into it vertex
array or into a buffer rather and then
I'm add it to a vertex array and then
you're all good also i might potentially
get rid of that x rays as well have
maybe two options because not all
platform support vertex arrays and
there's really a lot of stuff to talk
about but the idea is that's kind of
what I'm doing okay there's a two major
features that are in progress right now
and I'm a stream them if there's enough
interest for me to stream these the
reason I've been avoiding streaming it
is they're not particularly fun to watch
I think because they're just a lot of
refactoring and a lot of just especially
with the c-sharp kind of CLI generator
there's a lot of just mundane kind of
let's generate code kind of this didn't
work let's think about how we might do
this and it doesn't end up being that
productive and it's not that easy to
write either so there's a lot of um
there's a lot of just like kind of
staring and trying to figure things out
and I'm not a huge fan of doing that on
stream just because I don't think it
provides I don't think it provides I
don't think it's necessary to stream
that because it's not really that
interesting like if I was working on
like a 3d render for example that's
something that is much more fun and it's
something that that will of course be of
I would imagine be of more interest to
people but if I'm wrong if you do want
to see that just drop a comment below
let me know and we'll see what happen
with that okay the other thing that will
happen and this is like a this is like a
larger kind of long-term goal / feature
3d I've been meaning to get 3d in for a
really long time and I just I really
just haven't had time the next step you
can actually see I believe that I've
split up I don't know if this stuff is
committed i hope it is but I I split up
where is this graphics layers yeah it is
so layer layer has now been split up
into just a generic layer and you can
see that this layer is essentially just
in it on a van tech update and render
and this actually doesn't need to be
updated someone but layer 2 D is like
the 2d only kind of thing and you can
see it's got to render a 2d attached to
it it's got a bunch of renderable zits
got a shader one shredder as well so
each layer has its own shader and it's
got a projection matrix yep that's fine
and it's got all of that stuff and that
kind of gets applied to one layer and
this is very this is very specifically
to do okay so I've have started
separating things into 2d and 3d kind of
things I may actually make another
folder on here that deals with 3d
because again there's engine does
support or this engine should support
both equally like not kind of do 2d in a
3d way I don't want to do that I just
want to have complete 2d functionality
in complete 3d functionality as optimal
as they can be but yes 3d is definitely
coming soon I did tweet out recently and
I asked what you guys wanted to see just
generically in terms of videos and a lot
of people want to see 3d stuff so once I
do get started on three things and as I
start making 3d more and more in this
engine is because I know that it's
something that a lot of people really
want to see I will absolutely be making
dedicated videos probably standalone
videos that aren't really part of a
series just going over all the different
things that go into a 3d renderer and
just a 3d engine essentially okay now
that there are so many things here that
need to be done I've actually got a
massive list of things right on my other
monitor here that I won't go through
some of them right now but just a few
things that need to happen we need to
have some kind of build pipeline we need
some kind of automatic or automated
project setup so there'll be a tool that
will
ideally set up like a visual studio
project for you know all that stuff I
was going to actually started running a
visual to you plug in about half a year
ago which I kind of stopped for no
reason other than it wasn't that
necessary I think now it would be more
necessary though controller support so i
need to add game controller support that
should be relatively simple but that'll
be one of those things as platform
dependent windows is the is the platform
that i'm leading towards right now just
because i use it the most but eventually
will add different platforms of course
direct3d support one things that is
actually a kind of a longer term type
deal we also need some kind of yeah we
need to finish CLI of course we there
are some random optimization surrender
that i want to think about of course
entity component system is something i
want to implement as well as well as
box2d i've actually already put that
into the engine as you can see some of
the pendants ease i believe here it is
box2d so it's in there but it needs to
be actually hooked up and for that i
need some kind of energy component
system which i need to put in then of
course there's a bunch of stuff with 3d
that needs to happen WebGL still does
require glfw so i actually might undo my
whole getting a rid of glfw thing
because you know as you know right now i
basically got and when 32 window class
which basically just uses the win32 api
to actually generate window and that's
all nice but again it's not 100-percent
necessary i just wanted to do it so that
this engine had had as as as less
dependencies that work I don't even know
as little dependencies probably what I'm
going to say as little dependencies as
possible but I might bring back your
laptop is just because I'm scripting and
WebGL whoops still need that stuff the
other thing is Android and iOS those are
not things that I want to rush okay
those are not things that I am
necessarily itching to get done the
reason is I work at a mobile game studio
called fire monkeys which is an EA
studio and I work on the engine team
there and I develop mobile stuff pretty
much all day not to say that it's
explicitly mobile like it would be the
same for whatever platform you were
developing in for because I'm not
developing i have done actual android
kind of layer stuff so down in that kind
of link but usually it's kind of
abstract and away from platform
dependent code but still I hope well I'm
not really Russian to do that since I
did that every day at work so I would
rather get other platforms such as
Windows Mac and Linux down first and web
and then maybe I could put android and
iOS and iOS is going to be a little bit
more difficult to actually do just
because I need it Mac I've got a mac but
it's going to be difficult to switch
between the two and stream and that it
just needs a bit a bit of a better setup
really but I'm Android is generally
pretty easy to put in because envidio
have some great tools for that and that
shouldn't be too difficult I actually do
have an instance of this engine running
on Android I did that a while back I
just never committed it it totally works
is there's nothing here that doesn't
work with Android really you need to
write a very thin Java interface it just
loads this library really so it's very
easy to do and it's something that we
need to do but again unix kind of stuff
so Mac and Linux come before that in
terms of my priorities and as far as
bugs and issues goes ah there are some
shader compilation issues on AMD cards
which I need to figure out I don't have
an AMD card or Annie or really access to
any kind of AMD cards so I'm going to
probably get help from you guys for that
but I already know why it's happening I
just have to actually fix up the shader
it's like a warm line fix just because
AMD have some problems AMD that amd's
glsl compiler has a few issues with
texture arrays and whatnot or arrays of
textures I should say and also WebGL did
have a few glitches when I made shift
back in a lot of dare 32 whatever it was
there a to fix up now speaking of bugs
and issues as well I know this video is
dragging on now but I just say I wanted
it to be pretty detailed as far as as
far as issues go ah the github page I'm
actually going to start using this much
more seriously I really I really wish
that github had a better system for
dealing with issue tracking because this
is kind of annoying
like it's not really as complicated as
something like chira for example so jira
is um is way more way more comprehensive
and I actually quite like it it's it's
much better structured it's much more in
depth and you can see things like
timelines and you can have you can
basically set things as in progress for
example and you can assign it to people
you can do that here as well but it's
just it's this is very very minimalistic
and I guess you can have milestones and
things like that but basically the
reason I want to use this I could set up
a jira for Sparky if you guys are
interested in that or you think that
would be better then let me know but I'm
pretty sure that I'm just going to keep
it as github issues just because I know
everyone has a github account and and
you guys are probably much more likely
to contribute to these kind of list of
issues and you are to actually make an
account for jira and contributing with
it there as well as much of a licensing
for that would be because there's a lot
of people who want to probably
contribute here anyone can leave a
comment for example or open an issue
which is good but you can see there's
actually quite a few issues open I'm
going to start adding issues here these
are not just for issues by the way these
are the tasks as well I know what set of
issues but we're not going to use it for
that we're going to use it for issues of
bugs and tasks as well there's a bunch
of different labels you can give it such
as bug for example enhancement right all
that stuff that i'll add more of that we
can work on but basically I want to kind
of move this forward the other thing I
want to talk about is the Chado com
there is the Sparky engine forum right
so on the turnover home / forums we have
this barking engine forum which has all
the stuff and a lot of people post here
and whatnot it's been a while since I've
really been active in this but I might
bring some of that back more as we start
doing more regular videos and more
regular interaction on one or with that
but um that's kind of the idea okay so i
will do something like that and we will
get that show on the road so anyway
that's basically an overview of what's
why you
what will happen on Sparky game
programming right now is going to I'm
going to do that as I feel motivated to
do it which is kind of I don't know it's
just such an old project for me that it
feels like I'm not sure what's going to
happen with that obviously but um Sparky
is basically kind of what I want to
focus on really and I will be focusing
on that much more throughout Christmas
and all those holidays so anyway that is
the plan leave your thoughts in the
comments below please if you have any
kind of ideas or any comments really or
you want me to do this a certain way or
you're really excited for me to continue
doing this please let me know hit a like
button on the video if you want to see
more of Sparky and whatnot and yeah i
guess i'll see you guys in the future
and possibly on life change as well the
other thing you should do as well as
follow me on Twitter so it's sort of the
compo / the churn OB cuz i do this is my
twitter so you can see that i talked
about Sparky and whatnot today and in
the morning for example so i do a lot of
that stuff and if you want to really
kind of keep keep on keep on keep on
point you know keep updated about Sparky
and about that me generally then you
want to you would want to follow me
there because I announced a lot of
things there and I talked to the
community all of them as well so anyway
that's gonna wrap up this video's very
massive video but hopefully I've covered
everything that I wanted to cover and
and we'll see what the future holds
really but I'm really excited to be
working on this and hopefully we can
produce something that is quite cool
okay i will see you guys later goodbye